[Musique]
john kerry
[Applaudissements]
non non non non non qu'est ce que c'est
que ces histoires
comment tourner par rapport aux modèles
terriens contrairement à la légende
voilà mesdames messieurs vous l'assistez
1 c'est extrêmement important ce qui
s'est passé hier soir c'est le deuxième
scoop de la soirée patrick bruel va se
marier et jean claude moly embrasse les
filles avant d'en masse et les garçons
que ça à faire des tonnes non ah bon la
branche d'arbre assez dans les pôles oui
en même temps c'était pas très
compromettants je dois dire oui à temps
que se compromettant je trouve qu'elle
est très très joli et si tout est fait
comme ça il y aurait pas beaucoup de pdg
[Musique]
en train de gérer c'est lui il serait
bientôt a expliqué qu'il avait que des
tons quoi ouais en fait c'est ça
donc je veux briller vis en ce moment
vous êtes souvent à rome où vous vous
tournez concurrence déloyale d'ettore
scola avec gérard depardieu c'est ça et
claude rich et puis en fait c'est aussi
souvent à paris pour faire la promo de
votre livre enfin pour
[Musique]
mais chantal goya c'est chantal biya
c'est en hommage en fait on peut le dire
aujourd'hui c'est un match que j'ai
connu aussi l aube a alors ça s'appelle
le ruisseau des singes
alors on grosse j'explique à votre place
parce que j'avais tellement répété
galles et donc le ruisseau des singes
parce que vous étiez petit j'étais petit
aussi voilà et vous avez plus de 50 à
lui c'est cette même scène vous
souhaitez blida à la voilà si une soirée
on aurait pu se rencontrer parce que tu
es né il ya pas longtemps toi là c'est
une soirée souvenirs à tous vents
viennent chercher à l'école sera
accompagnée et serait un prix des trucs
bien sorti quelle est donc la recette
familiale
on a fait le grand nageur en calèche
tous les deux ans au maroc est au maroc
chez moi qui conduis je vais la tête
énorme ce que des scoops
et alors la promenade familiale du
dimanche se faisait à un endroit il
s'appelait les gorges de la chiffa des
petits singes où il y en avait une mine
mais à peu près de toutes les couleurs
des singes en liberté est mieux que
disneyland parce qu'ils venaient manger
des bananes voilà wet est alors pour
atteindre cet éden il y avait 40 km d'en
faire parce que vous étiez malade en
voiture une traction avant sa santé les
centres et 1900 temps de la faction à
nouveau me sied voila voila je rendais
là il rendait l'âme et jaune un peu
inespéré de d'image comme ça j'ai pensé
pour arriver au bonheur au paradis il
faut passer des obstacles style voilà du
genre thierry ardisson c'est une
métaphore c'est une métaphore de la vie
c'est titre alors oui justement dans les
choses désagréables avant d'atteindre le
bonheur via vos parents un parce que
c'est vrai que l'agréable ils n'ont rien
compris l'ombre et votre père était
militaire et il acceptait mal déjà que
vous fassiez le singe votre mère qui
vous disent et surtout te fait pas
remarquer alors pour vous connaissez
risque d'être difficile c'était comme
dira mozart fait pas de musique un peu
quoi c'est gentil ça si près c'est
gentil musiciens
et de retrait donc non mais quand vous
avez vu la logique vous avez la légion
d'honneur 80 bodmer lui est content de
sa mère c'est pas augustin bottemer elle
dit autre façon de nos jours il a donné
à tout le monde ce qui est vrai à peu
jusqu'à un peu vrai mais en même temps à
vrai dire j'étais pas très aimable
morceau mon fils et moi je joue au
théâtre elle disait que le partenaire
été formidable mais la fille était
magnifique
dender c'était habituel c'est ça va te
remercie pour ma mère c'est sympa donc
le livre commence par votre enfant
fils de militaire de casernes en caserne
à vous êtes né dans une caserne 1 et
puis après la guerre de choses ouais
c'est ça vous venez en métropole
marseille histoire proche et oui
semblait voilà alors là votre père
évidemment lui c'était un militaire
qu'est ce qu'il a fait pendant la guerre
lui là il s'est bien comporté
oui c'est bien comporté cette famille
cmao ont balancé par an une attitude un
peu je vous le dis à votre taille là une
attitude un peu tiède dans la gueule
non ils étaient tièdes comme je vous
signale que 50 millions de français
oui il était militaire le maréchal
pétain était le vainqueur de verdun
il pouvait pas penser qu'ils pourraient
y avait quelque chose de trop mal dont
il était un petit peu obéissant voilà je
lui ai reproché saleh d'avoir aidé
troupeau obéissant
vous savez il ya une phrase de vous dire
que je fais toujours des citations
toujours oui mais jusqu'à maintenant je
n'ai pas fait une seule salle alors je
vais en faire une literie tristan
bernard lestang bernard g disaient ils
croient qu'ils sont heureux parce qu'ils
sont immobiles et j'ai reproché à mon
père et à beaucoup de français moi
j'avais 8 ans d'être immobile alors il a
peut-être pas entendu général de gaulle
mais il était resté un peu tranquille et
je trouve que dans la vie il faut oser
même si on se trompe
oui et alors citation pour citations
c'est d'ailleurs marqué au début de
votre bouquin c'est j'écris mes mémoires
avant de ne plus en avoir
voilà on est un peu vieux on a des
rancunes des rangs des stands ehrlacher
il vaut mieux être généreux alors en 46
bon à la guerre est finie vous vous
retrouvez au prytanée militaire de la
flèche et une école d'enfants de troupe
vous ayez une photo d'ailleurs j'étais
en unissant mais on se levait à 5 ans le
matin on vous lit au carré on a stick et
autant de oui tu tapes a connu tout ça
pas mal regarde toi tu m'écoutes belge
voilà et c'est là où j'ai découvert la
mettiez pas ding ding boum boum larmes
de l'amitié oui l'amérique jours et 5
heures du matin qui m'a expliqué 5h du
matin ça c'est chic c'est déjà tomber
sur la gueule quand s'arrête demain
faute une issue qui a changé de cravates
va commencer parce que et pas même à
cravate
non si elle est bien sa cravate et leur
intensité leur mère décrite à 30 ans sa
mère sa cravate en jean claude brialy
sorte que quand il ya une cravate qui ne
me plaît pas je lui dit fil des années
qu'on est ensemble le matin candy par
les grottes qui me plaît pas
[Musique]
avoir un bon copain jacques brillet bon
alors vous êtes donc au prytanée
militaire et vous aller en vacances à
paris chez votre oncle et votre tante
qui vous amène voir joséphine baker
j'avais une tante qui était très gentil
pas de jeunes groupes
la soeur de ma mère qui était une femme
très sympathique parce que elle qu'elle
avait compris elle est ce que j'abats
huit frères et grâce à elle j'ai pu voir
des images qui ont sauvé c'est toute ma
vie
et oui et vous découvrez le théâtre donc
à baden oui oui d'abord là est cabré en
fait en 46 sabadell avec le fils du
consul général de france
oui qu'ils étaient fiancés ça c'est bien
correct les côtés et là vous rencontriez
dit je fais hier et jean marais ont
tourné à baden et vous rencontrer pierre
l'homme qui est un opérateur assez connu
un très important faisant nôtre en
faisant votre sage il a fait sans
hésiter à pierre lhomme philippe de
broca et robert ros et du pot toute
votre vie vous avez dû courir oui j'ai
toujours rencontré les gens qui
faisaient pas couché beaucoup
contrairement à ce qu'on croit et alors
quand vous êtes démobilisés vous allez à
paris avec vous avez fini votre service
mes gars vous a dit pour faire le
service avec quand vous avez fini vous
allez à paris il l'a alors se faisait
m'expliquer comment avec une seule de 26
francs par jour vous êtes arrivé à
économiser 60 mille francs pris le
départ hier
nous savions votre mère ça votre côté
bas de laine comme ça pas madeleine je
n'aime pas que je trouve que j'aime pas
du tout de même pris pour l'argent mais
je n'aime pas le gaspiller votre petite
maison 18e la petit château le très
jeune à 23 à 23 ans donc j'avais un côté
quand même vous attendez à voir une
maison à 23 ans parce qu'on a travaillé
simplement ma mère m'a dit qu'on avait
vu ma maison il m'a dit mais tu as
besoin de ça pour toi tout seul
ouais bah oui j'étais content d'avoir
une maison est ce que j'irai vais tout
mal mais regardez par exemple au
cimetière acheté une concession
non attendez vous acheter une concession
au cimetière une première concession à
côté de marie commission à côté des habs
en acheter d'autres
la maison est comme les discours
politiques quand on veut couper dans la
phrase on peut arranger vous achetez
deux helpes accession j'aie jamais senti
et non avec la clim et sais pas non
j'espère qu'on sera 4 ha ha ha c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs assez pour mettre des
copains et vous comprenez pas pourquoi
vous une double concession vous j'ai pas
une double concession c'est un petit peu
plus grand que d'habitude
la troupe s'est ajoutée la dame aux
camélias côtés de marie dupuis l'instant
ces gens une grande précision
oui je ferai des soirées comme je peux
dire que même même sa tombe est chouette
quoi comme le maire alors vous dites les
gens du cahier la bande des cahiers du
cinéma
quand vous étiez à paris au début je
crois 55 56 oui ils vous payez votre
place au cinéma quand j'ai vu les rires
oui alors ciment cette idée vous êtes
toujours fait rire les gens présents
place et en août à pied la tête contre
les murs si ça faisait rire les gens
âgés fait très con mais bon si ça fait
rire les cheveux faisait mal
nous continuons d extraordinaire que
maintenant je me fais plus malin si
c'est pas difficile d'être sens à la
représentation de vouloir séduire d'être
aimé de j'avais pas ça chez moi on ne me
comprenait pas donc je voulais père à
l'extérieur et comme je suis joyeux
séduisait déco pas lieu j'ai compris le
rire c'était la première séduction une
femme vous dira toujours un homme qui me
fait rire laboral la lie tout à l'heure
en parlant de son copain quelqu'un qui
vous fait rire son copain à new york et
en même temps oui bah là
il a fait rire de new york alors si on
en a les murs et claire secret votre
secret pour vous faire des nouveaux
merveilleux amis que vous avez cédé
avoir fait rire
d'abord je crois que j'étais gentil je
faisais rire et je partais quand il
fallait et je ne demandais rien en
amitié il faut jamais yann moix code
comme ça on vous donne alors votre
bouquin bon il faut le dire un peu son
jeu pas de raconter 454 oui bon il est
rue cas c'est marrant quand même il ya
deux l'on vous fait le pitre toujours
voulu écrire au festival de cannes pour
y devenir copains et qui a été beau à
oui ça veut dire que dois je vois des
jeunes premiers d'aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'on est très très beau je regarde pas
alors il n'y a pas photo y'a pas photo
non content de cette anecdote qui est
assez rigolote donc vous devenez copain
avec lui au festival de cannes pour
monter à paris à l'époque il vit avec
brigitte aubert a surpris ce qui était
d'un rendez-vous juillet de jacques
becker il faut le signaler ce n'est pas
un soir du dîner tous les 3 8 10 ans
sort oui bon et d'histoire tu viens pas
il dit oui non et michaud avec mon
copain on va faire un petit tour al dib
et moi je n'en ont cure et à la maison
tranquille sympa mais bon
j'en connais d'autres avouent façade
avec john m à oui donc banon d'accord
tous les cas il fait ça et puis là il
vendait que la voiture elle ne peut pas
lui donner parce que dit puisque tu veux
sortir
riton copa va à pied ouais alors il sort
un revolver en or quand bush envers les
coûts non matin de deux fois vingt
structures comme ça promet pour
m'impressionner il voulait faire gary
cooper pour moi très bon et puis après
il met à deux filles il fait pas très
beau tir non il tire dans la serrure de
la bagnole et qu'un plein oui mais a
pris mais les deux chiens tout ce soir
sur la première fois qu'il me faisait
oui mais donnant donnant maintenant
parce que quand on connaît quelqu'un qui
veut faire une biographie de vie pour
raconter tout ça il interdit en même
temps vous vous en êtes pas du tout
raconte des conneries et quand tu auras
cours des méchancetés et des trucs moi
j'ai vécu deux ans avec lui que
j'entends aujourd'hui qu'on dise pour un
verre de whisky on pouvait avoir de
longues cdrs je trouve ça ne c'est pas
vrai absolument pas vrai les papas
compte trois bouteilles de champagne
parce que j'allais dire que j'allais
dire de verre mais je préfère vous dites
vous alors vous raconter que l'on aime
pour une bd du chah puis à les
accueillir michener d'air donc
longuement devenir également évident et
là vous assister à la naissance d'une
passion entre les deux un coup de foudre
journée crise dans six mois et alors le
soir ce rigolo ça vous allez au lido
tous les trois de long il prend des
langoustes du champagne
il voulait épater encore plus
mademoiselle joubert d'abord qu'il
n'avait pas la donne ça à la télé à
tomber dans le piège
elle avait plongé dans ses grands yeux
bleus et il dit ont valu doji battant de
paron il faudra au lido bon tu es toi
bon alors on va au lido moi je me bats
en paroles de table il connaissait
directeur on à la table du milieu on
nous a même caviar
moi j'étais angoissé fils de militaire
un peu comme ça j'ai passé deux mois
faire la vaisselle
ça va ça va être terrible puis quand on
va porter l'addition que l'on va faire
rage et et transpirer jeu pour eux il
était heureux amoureux ils se
regardaient et buvait du champagne ça la
musique y dansait votre comme un conte
j'attendais la sédition toute la soirée
et puis à minuit minuit et demi le
spectacle est terminé
l'orchestré gentil fait une valse pour
robin haase chrome était une star
internationale et on lui joue l'aval de
6,6 elle se lève de l'empa avec lé voilà
qui dans tous les deux et moi je me suis
là terrorisée et bien eu ce qui arrive
le maître d'hôtel à aimer mais
l'addition devant les yeux à moi alors
je vois la laissions c'était une 4000
francs 5000 francs c'était épouvantable
pour moi c'était six mois de salaire
veulent bon je dis bon oui tout de suite
tout de suite au visage plein air d'un
dollar revient juge judy cela dit sion
discrètement parce qu'on est avec une
dame
il regarde et dit alors ah ben je dis
alors quoi et bien alors on m'y a
compris le manège a pris l'addition à la
signer c'est elle qui nous a invité le
soir j'espère qu'il ait un style ces
pages il aura donc non jamais alors
edith piaf auriez eu un truc ici un soir
patrick sébastien nous a raconté que
chaque fois qu'il mettait une cassette
de piaf dans sa mercedes
il avait un accident et quelqu'un a
parlé de vous en disant mais jean claude
brialy
il a hérité de la petite robe noire de
de piaf est la première fois qu il a
voulu la montrer à quelqu'un la petite
robe noire de piaf
le téléphone a sonné hop c'était pierre
brasseur qui était mort oui la deuxième
fois qu'il la menthe le téléphone sonne
et c'était au sahara pau le dernier
jules de piac était mort donc j'y
retrouvais ça en fait dans l'hôtellerie
dite était quelqu'un des cas une
présence si fort mais c'est fort que je
pense qu'elle veut pas qu'on emmerde
elle est contente qu'on l'entend de
chanter encore 35 ans après sa mort et
d'antonne cette voix unique et des ses
chansons d'amour mais il était très
superstitieuse et je crois qu'elle n'est
pas contente quand on touche à sa vie
privée ou à des choses personnelles bien
quand on a fait que deux louches
le film
edith et marcel bon j'avais dit à quoi
tu es sûr qu'il m'a dit oui moi j'ai
rencontré pierre elle était contente
qu'on va sa vie et puis c'est vrai que
le premier jour des essais patrick
dewaere se suicident l'arrêt qui devait
jouer un set ça doit donc tout d'un coup
il ya une pression dans le film et le
film n'a pas très bien marché alors
qu'il était très bien fait équipe d'une
brique c'était formidable
mais ça n'a pas marché bon théo sarapo
que je connaissais avec est dit est dit
m'avait dit si que je meurs tu t'occupes
de théo tout le monde va laisser tomber
ce qui a été fait d'ailleurs dès qu'elle
est morte
donc j'ai à prêter au jeu dit viens chez
moi dans ma belle maison pour passer 15
jours ou trois semaines peut être
tranquille pas avoir la pression de la
presse des photos pour me remercier m'a
offert des livres
et puis la petite une d une des petites
robes avec quatre petites robes de
scènes de desdites avec deux petits
coeurs comme ça c'était elle apprend
j'ai mis dans un carton et du papier de
soie et puis j'ai jamais je suis pas
fétichiste je veux pas voir là la robe
desdites la nuit etc
un jour c'est vrai des amis m'ont parlé
des dykes m'ont parlé de pierre brasseur
en disant j'ai toujours bourré c'est un
conte qui fait rage des furieux parce
que j'adore les pierre brasseur et je
dis je vais vous montrer là il est ami
avec edith piaf quand on est ami avec
elite gaffe c'est un honneur donc je
vais vous montrer la robe de scène
d'édith au moment où je monte pour la
chercher téléphone solaire la pierre
venait mourir c'est à deux ans plus tard
la même chose et c'était au qui venaient
se tue en voiture
et voilà la robe et voilà alors bon donc
votre bouquin regorge d'histoires comme
ça qu'ils sont qui soit la pj regorge
record je sais bien que comme ça regorge
d'histoires comme ça mais c'est vrai il
ya plein de la dissidence est tous des
gens qu'on a connus lino ventura qui
parlait trop bas lors les les ingé son
idole et arletty qu'il voulait plus dire
atmosphère atmosphère parce que visait
le public le dit mieux que moi c'est
vrai elle meurt dans la misère a pris
quand elle est morte on découvre je paye
un tableau du trio c'est gonzague pas le
mieux c'est jules hméun à huy à jbeil
formidable jubert il avait une une
chambre de bonne qui montrait aux
huissiers il habitait au genre je me tue
à reinach monsieur monsieur andré qui
était un type extraordinaire très
élégant qui était qu'avait le
à deauville le de normand dire tous les
essais toute la suite de barrières bon
ils avaient tous ses hôtels ses casinos
ils étaient très riches mais il aimait
les artistes et jules berry joue au
casino tout le temps donc il avait dû
pas beaucoup au casino de deauville au
casino de cannes ou bon alors donc qu'il
avait une grande amitié pour berry et
ils lui avaient donné une suite
alan à la vie au george saga c'était son
hôtel et il avait une petite chambre de
bonne pour les huissiers se donner ainsi
arriver en disant au monsieur berry il a
il habite là-bas au 9e étage alors
embauché envoyé à lille quand un cintre
vide
et puis rien donc il pouvait rien saisir
et le taux central du ve et du champagne
élevé il ya un mot très très charmant de
marcel andré et de jus bien un jour
jules berry envoie un télégramme à
monsieur andré à deauville au lisa
envoient moins urgents 5000 francs je le
dirai à tout le monde et monsieur et
monsieur andré a dit voilà 500 francs ne
le dis à personne agissant comme ça
c'est un petit peu comme si vous
invitiez gentilhommerie a dîné avec un
demi de ma voix vous acheter
un petit problème simplement c'est que
vous parlez de tout le monde vous
parlait très peu de vous dans ce bouquin
il faut attendre la page 414 sur 450
pour vous évoquiez votre homosexualité
alors que c'est un truc que tout le
monde connaît bien ce programme étalé je
m'en fous complètement j'ai pas une
étoile rose ici je prône à vous parler
de racisme et tout ça je pense que quand
il ya de l'amour coup que ce soit
maintenant les cépages porte pas un
jugement de leurs je dis simplement la
homosexuels ans à jeudi 5 h 10 à bhl je
m'en fous je le sais et vous attendez la
page 414 pour évoquer voulons c'est
vraiment mon éditeur qui monsieur fixot
way m'a dit mais tu parles jamais ta vie
privée gidon d'ailleurs j'ai fait une
page blanche
ce qu'il aurait fallu à lire mon chien
fois raconté tout mais alors j'ai donc
mis une page blanche a aimé ce que j'ai
croisé un ma vie je je les salue
mais peuvent à ce que chacun leur nom
ouais ils ont les traits à anjouan et
mayotte ya beaucoup de filles dans votre
vie contre c'est pour ça que
l'homosexualité était bilingue mon cher
et et puis c'est vrai d'avoir d'abord
quand je suis arrivé à paris j'ai tombé
amoureux des mots tout mais on aurait pu
penser que c'était des gens marrer un
bon j'ai rencontré dans la vie va garder
en otage nous avait présenté un truffaut
absolue pour qu'elle reste mon amie et
ma marraine de théâtre
je vais vous faire ça vous étonnera pas
jean claude brialy je veux faire une
interview cire pompes
[Musique]
il n'a pas bougé comme jean rolin thème
cire-pompes j'aurais pu l'appeler
l'interview drucker mais je l'appelle la
con mais pas désagréable avec michel ce
qui nous regarde des jouets 600 fois la
puce à l'oreille de 150 fois mon père
avait raison entre 1
vous êtes quand même aussi un immense
acteur de théâtre non je pense je suis
un immense inconsciente elle serpente
ah oui d'accord avec un bruit sur quoi
je crois que je suis bien mon métier que
j'aime bien
alors on continue interview sur pompe
patron de théâtre des bouffes parisiens
mais pas d'un restaurant laurie vous
réussissez tout ce que vous touche à
l'âme vous verrez que je voudrais tout
chez elle devenir directeur que cet été
vous allez faire deux festivals le
festival d'anjou quai de ramatuelle et
de ramatuelle
il ya un festival sacha guitry à dax
troisième festival non à la jambe gauche
bien sûr je viens jouer la pièce et
ouais avec mon père avait raison au
prétexte qu à dax un grand hôtel grand
hôtel où aller sachez qu on a ramené ces
femmes là il s'ennuyait tellement il
disait elle s'ennuie tellement kopstal
on peut faire l'amour toute la journée
c'est bien c'est joli
dites moi on peut dire votre âge ah oui
67 ans nous devons bien pour votre âge
oui et au lit je suis à jeune homme un
jeune homme qu'elle est quel est votre
secret jean claude brialy en secret
c'est que je crois que j'aime les autres
et que je dors bien voilà je crois que
quand on aime les autres
vous savez il ya une très belle phrase
d'arletty elle disait la meilleure gamme
de beauté c'est la bonne conscience
et quand on sent dans le soir en ayant
fait ce qu'on devait faire de ce travail
qu'on a été sincère et qu'on a essayé de
donner la main à l'autre on dort bien
nommé vous entendez l'aï meilleures
crèmes de beauté c'est la bonne
conscience elle n'a pas besoin de crème
de beauté les ravissantes non mais
attends mais j'ai eu quand même le droit
de dire que vous allez ravissante là
mais je pense à
voilà merci à lui et maintenant
[Musique]
voici jean claude brialy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
ok
[Applaudissements]
là ça va bien oui j'ai regardé un peu
l'émission c'est un peu mais 68,1 et
c'est bien ça des barrages année mais
surtout certains incertain c'est vrai
que monsieur comme comme guy je préfère
les films 1 le goupil il est sincère il
est romantique
il m'a fait penser à sa juste mais très
bien connu alors on va commencer pour se
mettre en jambe par quelques part
quelques questions de journalistes
débutants marseille je sais pas si ça
vous arrive non mais ça m'est arrivé il
ya maintenant 50 ans les journalistes
débutants c'est à dire les mecs qui vous
disent par exemple jean claude brialy
vous faisiez quoi avant de faire des
séries télé un petit peu de cinéma est
ce que vous faites maintenant c'est un
choix et une vocation
4 vous pensez vous avez enfin trouver
votre voie après toutes ces années je
crois tu envie de jouer toi il est rayé
très les joueurs très espiègle mais
jugeant inutile aussi en tout cas pour
toi est ce que vous pensez être un
modèle pour les gens qui vous admirent
j'espère un votre carrière c'est un coup
de chance ou beaucoup de boulot c'est
beaucoup de chance et beaucoup de boulot
ouais quels conseils donneriez-vous à un
jeune comédien qui débute ne couchez pas
quels conseils donneriez vous à un vieux
comédien qui débute
friess ayant encore un petit coup 1 et
quels conseils donneriez-vous un
comédien qui se fout complètement de la
vie de jean claude brialy
tu as raison quels conseils
donneriez-vous un vieil animateur télé
elissa pour lui ouais j'aime beaucoup
jean pierre foucault
attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors jean claude brialy vos mémoires la
rivière des singes mais je suis débutant
avait toujours dans le débutant je sais
se sont vendues à 60 mille exemplaires
c'est bien c'est en 1600 misé millions
six tunisien passe est-ce que vous allez
à nous raconter votre n'a qu'une vie
alors je vais faire le pas la suite d'un
petit journal a compris la question et
d'anticiper du pouvoir les rejets encore
l'esprit vie où il reste a du mal à
suivre
ah ça on va voir magnéto sérieusement
vous allez encore raconter votre vie une
fois non pas ma vie mes gens que je
croise il ya pas longtemps j'ai un temps
une dame qui m'a dit les compliments
c'était très charmant elle m'a dit je
suis contente de vous voir de votre
vivant
alors c'est vrai c'est vrai 2010 est
positionné jean paul briat lille
alors en attendant jean claude brialy
vous publié au cherche midi
les répliques les plus drôles du cinéma
wahou
comment ça s'est passé vous l'histoire
plein de films j'imagine le danger qu'il
faut dire que je suis très copain ami
avec les amis du cherche-midi way qui
travaille très bien qu'ils font n'est
pensé de bedos une spéciale sur ce midi
à lui jean yanne et de coluche et
d'autres lâchers chabrol et prévôt et
prévaut ce sont vraiment des amis et mon
lit voilà on a une équipe qui a fait un
répertoire et qui a trouvé des répliques
formidable dans des films moyens
quelques fois et je dois dire que je me
suis beaucoup amusé en lisant les
épreuves j'en ai ajouté 2 3 et j'ai fait
la préface c'est tout j'ai pas fait
brouillon l'avoir trouvée je n'ai rien
volé c'est le bon boulot mais ils ont
bien à la télé pour dire à ses vaches
mères voilà un roc est vraiment très
très très moche
est ce qu'il ya une réplique de vous
avez eu à prononcer dans un film et que
qui n'est pas dans le bouquin dont il ya
les frais des choses très bizarres
devant les cousins mon premier fils à
papa mon premier film populaire avec
chabrol paul gégauff avait écrit une
petite scène où je parle en allemand
avec une casquette de l'officier
allemand en feu à erich von stroheim
écart était saisissant alors oui je
faisais je le compte toujours pour
amuser chabrol truffaut et godard avec
une limitation des riffauds sereine dans
la grande illusion gégauff lemay dallas
dallas dans le film et chabrol
au moment de tourner dit non c'est pas
bien ça va faire trop repasle m alors je
dis j'assiste plus tard qu'un petit
numéro quand même d'acteurs alors il dit
maintenant alors je tourne tout seul
sans chabrol qui va jouer au baby-foot
au café du coin et j'écris très vite un
petit texte en allemand très simple il
vinal heinola m
on ne fera taire nos moteurs etc est ce
cette scène a marqué le film dans le
monde entier et tout le monde me disait
c'est beau ce que tu dis de goethe
les flics les plus drôles du cinéma
recherche clinique présentée par
jean-claude brialy voilà alors vous êtes
toujours beaucoup d'activités 1
vous êtes patron des bouffes parisiens
directeur directeur des bouffes
parisiens et vous accueillez vous qu'on
produise est une pièce qui s'appelle les
oies du capital de philippe et cédric du
monde c'est sur de jeunes voilà green
tout très drôle c'est drôle mise en
scène de jacques de combat le pitch un
couple d'artisans quinquagénaire
reconverti dans le gardiennage
d'immeubles et pour s'évader de ce
quotidien un petit peu difficile
il regarde tous les jours le braz et des
passions à la télévision qui est une
série télé américaine dont les héros
finissent par devenir leur ami
voilà dix ans foutu à la porte des
appels au secours mais c'est très drôle
c'est complètement fou c'est burlesque
est plutôt que pour l'été les gens ont
envie de s'amuser puissant des gens
jeunes qui sont pas très connus et
quentin théâtre est fermée l'été c'est
comme une maison en deuil donc voilà
alors donc les joueurs je lis je dois
c'est très joli et on entend beaucoup
d'intrants et l'offrir oui je te dis que
c'est très gentil merci je mettrai mon
numéro
j'ai déjà d'eau quel est votre secret
pour faire autant de choses jean claude
brialy et oui on ne fait beaucoup de
choses que dans les airs la vieillesse
cnav en promo parce qu'ils ne parlent
qu'en citation quel est votre secret
pour voir tant d'amis garde tes amis
près de toi et tes tenues plus pas
encore le par un panel beaucoup d'amis
les tombes aucun
l'économie à la maison à la maison c'est
pareil m'emmerde à la maison d'arrêt
s'est renseigné il aime pas si monsieur
est difficile le matin on ne peut pas se
réveiller
le soir il veut pas se coucher toujours
pareil à une chose un trouvait à 27
quels autres secrets pour rester pote
avec alain delon a c'est un vieux vieux
souvenir
1 oui c'est pour ça non non c'est vrai
que quand on a débuté avec quelqu'un
qu'on a passé des moments de jeunesse
ensemble mais je même quelquefois je
suis pas d'accord avec lui je le lui dis
alors on est fâché pendant huit jours 1
mais ce qui l'a 10 entre deux longs en
parlant de long il a dit la première
impression est toujours la bonne surtout
quand elle est mauvaise joli
les amoureux sont seuls au monde et
alors c'est dans quoi ça parce que je me
la suis réservé aux seuls au monde avec
louis jouvet dany robin gt2
quel est votre secret pour avoir les
cheveux blancs et l'égard des blancs
comme ça la nature je couche avec lada
tu es et tu vois pareil pareil quel est
votre secret pour ne pas vous endormir
la cérémonie des molières j'y vais pas
mais je trouve que quand j avais
l'intelligence je te dormi à 5 ans braga
quel est votre secret pour passer des
vacances gratuites à ramatuelle
je fais un festival et j'habite chez les
autres
quel est votre secret pour vous pour
supporter toutes les vieilles dont vous
vous occupez elles me font rire vous
avez ce que m'a dit arédien je voudrais
reprendre tout ça pour vous la meilleure
crème de beauté c'est la bonne
conscience à alors ça ça bouvet a triché
et pourtant la pâte et gérer la bonne
conscience en jean claude brialy quand
je pense à vous moi je pense à une
phrase c'est je m'en suis occupé jusqu'à
la fin ah oui c'est bien ça c'est un peu
votre de vis oui oui il faut pas laisser
tomber les amis quoi qu'il arrive de
lourdes usa d'ailleurs quelqu'un cas
depuis je reçois chez moi moi non
ce soir c'est votre tour jean claude
volot
elliott le temps se gâte
beaucoup d'immeubles pour nous dire
c'est très beau
il y avait deux ce qui se dit [ __ ]
quand je pense que ce serait une arrivée
nous en plaindre
un tabou
non
[Applaudissements]
voilà jaune
ce soir ce soir c'est son tour
t'imagines sérieux y avait il y avait
chez pas si c'est dans le bouquin il y
avait une réplique me faisait beaucoup
rire c'est mourier gros mourir maigre la
différence et pour les porter et son
piquet a dit l'important c'est ce qu'il
ya dans la boîte
[Rires]
thomas heureusement je suis pas
superstitieux non content c'est une
façon de conjurer le sort
ils pensent que dix ans de plus ça va là
bas alors comme ça jean claude brialy
vous êtes mort un petit peu c'est pour
relancer votre carrière que vous faites
semblant d'être mort pagé galamaz pib
très très cher est est ce que c'est pour
avoir un hommage aux césar
non je préférais avoir un hommage tout
court à notre dame de paris
variable vous êtes mort comment brut
brutalement en vous regardant la
télévision
[Rires]
derrière un problème commun il ya un
problème parce que maintenant je ce camp
du plantier mort vous bon vous êtes mort
aussi comment on va faire pour les
enterrements qui va prononcer les
oraisons funèbres a demandé à guy bedos
non c'est fou et j'ai maintenant envie
de de dire quoi que ce soit ou je suis
trompé muet ce serait absolument
lamentable parce que je peux pas dire
deux mots et je me trouve tellement
émouvant moi même ouais qu'est-ce qui a
réuni sa lenteur improbable de plus je
suis mort il est mort et jean-claude
vous êtes mort qu'est ce qui va nous
casser les chemises avec la vie
d'arletty j'espère qu'elle va revenir
vous tirez traduit sans le savoir elle
sait toucher comme hommage vous préférez
la rediffusion d'un téléfilm sur france
2 ou un char à la gay pride
je préférerais qu'on avoue ma relation
avec fogiel
est-ce que
est ce que vous pensez qu'un jour une
rue portera votre nom une place chéri
une place faut-il rire de la mort nazis
mais on peut en mer il faut rire de les
tuer je me pousse et je te passe une
petite place
on va nous réduire l'un et l'autre on va
vous mettre dans des petits beaucoup
touché le père et la mère la chaîne ne
bouge vraiment si c'est confortable dans
la malle aux fesses à branler bourges où
le 10 mois vous avez bien trop longue
possible il ose enfin j'ai regretté des
anges est pas le diable diable ouais
c'est un peu mais un diable avec une
toute petite queue
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les
j'accueille matin jean claude brialy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir jean claude van damme délicat
délicat qui a le geste qu'ils s'essuient
très légèrement la bouche avant
d'embrasser d'accord d'accord non mais
c'est parce que c'est pas mon emploi
bien jean claude brialy donc après le
succès du ruisseau des singes sept cent
mille exemplaires miracle et il est pas
sortie à lourdes c'est un homme vraiment
un miracle gros succès alors après on
vous a demandé d'écrire une seconde
autobiographie
oui je parle m penser à l'om c'est que
vous avez qu'une vie donc c'est
compliqué d'écrire deux auto bilan parce
que j'avais envoyé 950 places à la
première fois et puis j'avais enlevé
quatre cents pages donc géré puiser dans
lesquels 100 pages et combien mes 10 ans
qui s'était passé
celui là s'appelle j'ai oublié de vous
dire chez xo éditions
c'est déjà en tête des ventes je n'ai
vendu 350 milles déjà 50 milles en 3
semaines
oh la la alors vous raconter des tas
d'anecdotes évidemment comme d'habitude
c'est super bowl par exemple sacha
guitry
moi je savais pas que quand il est tombé
amoureux yvonne printemps il allait
promener son chien
mais surtout il avait installé un judas
pour la survoler la chambre de sa femme
est la sienne et il ya mieux un passe
plat entre les deux pour voir si elle
était toujours là il y avait une petite
pieds en or il l'enfermé après l'avoir
honoré qu'il enfermait ylang-ylang fermé
il faut pas qu'elle sorte
et quand elle a connu pire freiner puis
à freiner ces mises en avant face la
chambre de la fenêtre de yvonne
printemps et avec sa cigarette user du
morse pour lui dire je fasse
voilà le problème le problème c'est
quand jean claude brialy sera plus là
pour nous raconter toutes ces belles
histoires
vous lirez vous lirez mon livre ma mère
la chaise comme disait le luron elle
sera plus là la merde lâche est alors
pierre brasseur lui s'est fait piquer sa
femme par une autre femme ça ça le
faisait chier parce qu'il se disait
quand même un seder c'est un peu de ma
faute
il vient dans mon tout petit appartement
pour réveillonner
et il vient avec sa femme qui était une
grande pianiste très très belle et très
élégante et très charmante et moi
j'habitais avec une copine qui avait
sais pas où dormir qui s'appelait
picoler fiscaux laisse donc un pic
honnête elle était un peu comme ça ma
repos pour le coacher
là est tombée amoureuse de la femme de
pierre bon alors je lui dis ce calme et
je suis mon copain tu es mon avis tu es
folle ou quoi et l'autre malheureusement
est tombée amoureuse de picoler donc
elle on veut s'en porter ensemble alors
pierre me dise le dos cocu myay je veux
bien me parut alors elles ont monté un
restaurant avait laissé ça il avait
laissé une maison qu'il avait à grimaud
à sa femme parce qu'il était très
élégant et très généreux et puis il
apprend que l on fait un très bon
restaurant qui était la coqueluche de la
côte d'azur alors pierre ces furieux ils
descendent dans le midi ils étaient
complètement bourré il va à grimaud iran
dans le restaurant il se pète dans tous
les clients qui bouffe équipe b il nous
à brian épices et voilà ce que je fais
et s'était trompé de restaur voilà alors
on apprend dans une fine vous avez été
là monde
havas garner mon cher jean claude brialy
dans quelles circonstances
c'était un miracle comme le la réussite
du livre j'étais à rome je tournais un
film et puis elle est d'être bon
magnifique et elle m'a choisi c'est elle
qui m'a moselle elle était très comment
dirais je sortais d'un une histoire
d'amour avec un grand acteur comique
s'appelait valtat khiari donc elle
buvait beaucoup et là les deux boîtes en
boîte de restaurants restaurant moi
j'étais mignon elle m'a vue elle m'a
mangé tout cru et voilà et j'étais très
heureux parce que
d'abord j'ai eu beaucoup de chance et au
début de ma carrière j'ai choisi plus
tard mais en montant les escaliers de
l'excelsior je me suis dit la tête de
belmondo et de longs matches oh oui je
fais le patcher on apprend que jamais
été l'amant d'ava gardner mais aussi de
rudolf noureev ce que je ne savais ce
qu'est une scène un repli qui est
extraordinaire c'est dans cet hôtel
particulier où je raconte ça parce que
c'est drôle parce que c'était à londres
luchino visconti donné à grand dîner
parce que pour nous rien et puis c'est
un truc assez chic assez dégarni relief
était habillé comme un muschick jamais
du smoking mais avec un charme fou
on le met en face d'eux le kilo moi
j'étais très jeune à l'époque donc on
met au bout de la table vont très bien
et puis au bout de cinq minutes je sens
bien au relief qu'il s'ennuyait
commencer ça le fait chier il se l'est
mis samba et en passant devant moi il me
jette un petit bout de papier devant
tout le monde alors moi je dis ça je
regardais il y avait son numéro de
téléphone appel et voilà si vous l'avez
appelé we call me baby mini stage avait
compris bon mais je rentre à l'hôtel
après avoir envisagé ce que le dessert
est arrivé en fragilité assez impatient
il était la beauté même buste à dans le
sort magique de corps bien fait
non mais c'était un danseur magique une
offre et puis bon à la maison aussi et
je sais que je sorte de l'hôtel je
prends mon taxi je vais retrouver le
danseur russe
et puis l'autre il était en robe de
chambre rouge avec des cierges partout
il y avait de la musique on va sauter la
police champagne et j'ai fait dans la
nuit je croise est toutefois paris saint
pétersbourg comme ce à quoi j'étais donc
très heureux c'est discret quand même
sur ce qui s'est passé avec la rime un
peu bizarre du matin
alors là ce moment là des cierges
partout bref voilà alors y'a plein de
choses dans ce bouquin à charles trenet
dont on apprend qu'il faisait jamais
rien sans être payés vous dites de
l'argent l'argent le séjour oui oui mais
en même temps je dis aussi que c'était
le plus grand poète qu'on a eu à la
chanson ouais admiration que j'ai pour
lui n'est sans borne simplement à notre
demande
je me demande de venir chanter
ramatuelle pour la dernière fois il
avait 75 ans il dit je ne chante plus
mais je pour toi je venais rabat où elle
s'est ou ramatuelle juillet près de
saint tropez
bon il 17 ans alors je dis bon ben on va
essayer de payer c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent
je m'arrange trouve des sponsors les
mécènes etc il vient il
on pourrait l'appeler contre midi 12h05
alors j'appelle à 12h04 et je lui dis tu
n'oublies pas que le doubs de 13 août tu
viens chanter à ramatuelle
on l'avait un contre un mais enfin comme
il est étrange et mu alors il ferait
tout simplement que tu viens de me
remettre un prix que j'ai eu le plus
grand prix au canada au québec
alors je dis mes coups charles tu sais
c'est un gros voyage ouais mais via
vient sinon je lui ai pas chanter je
vais donc au québec là on lui demande de
chanter deux chansons mais les papilles
y chante pas donc je remets le prix dans
sa voiture vas y viens pas
enfin ça a été un faux ni total et puis
enfin arrive le jour de ramatuelle et
deux jours avant ils déforment les uns
écoutent jia kellock tu veux venir
l'atabal ans et demi je serai la halle 6
heures je serai à 6h pour les accueillir
et puis de la coume fêter les fleurs
bizarres je virais à 8h bon je me serais
là 8 heures ça commençait à 9h30 et bien
ce que tu as pia pas n'y a pas d'hôtel
sympathique parce que je suis un gentil
mais je serai fatigué après que le
changer mais bien sûr j'ai un très bon
hôtel à ramatuelle où il ya cinq étoiles
enfin formidable and on m'a parlé d'un
petit hôtel sympathique à saint tropez
byblos et sa bible à 13 août
donc je téléphone le patron du bibelot
moi je ne connais pas mais qui me dit
monsieur brialy pour monsieur trenet
j'adore mais je traînais je vais j'ai
pas de place mais je m'arrange et il
faut des allemands d'or et trouver une
grande chambre propose al arish à la 8
heures
il prend le micro comme ça que j ai pas
bon secours non c'est celui compte
annoncer à pathé marconi non non non
c'est le micro d'amérique que tu nous a
demandé non non non non c'est pas bon ça
ça grésille je ne peux pas chanter donc
je chante pas alors je sois prêt lui je
lui dis mais c'est ton micro il y avait
heureusement ce merveilleux nicolas qui
était le contrebassiste de brassage bon
lui qui était trempée dans l'eau dans le
vin blanc et le père noël attend dès le
matin donc été complètement pp je dis
monsieur nicolas ça serait gentil de
médée dit que charles trenet à une très
jolie la boit alors il va s'assurer
avant que charles commencé à chanter dit
une très jolie vous gêne antibes après
il faut le dire mais bon là bas ils
chantent 30 chansons sublimes
sublimissime merveilleux et de belles
jambes on connaît et après je dis tu
sais le président d'air inter tu as fait
un dîner 250 personnes qu'il reste un
quart d'heure j'y vais pas alors comment
ça a du charme
je dis je vais faire une table à pas
avec tes amis alors on l'avait mis au
milieu jean lemay d'un côté j'appelle
jean pierre aumont javel des amis
charmant et puis il commence à voir un
petit peu de vin blanc il était heureux
tout allait bien et qu'on va s'agir
aujourd'hui une petite chanson et puis
arrive le président d'air inter qui
avait quand même donné 10 briques pour
veut le faire venir et le président est
un terreau lui dis je vraiment c'est une
des plus belles soirées que j'aurai
passé
alors moi je les ai pas pour le prix
c'est normalement et charges générées
garde le président des interdits je n'ai
pas ma carte évasion les 30% et après il
ya le patron d'ubs il ose qui passe il
vit finalement je vais rentrer voilà et
là on en arrive alors à ce qui est de
plus
scoop esque dans votre choisi on envie
de vous scoop être assez joli ces îles
mon temps nu et voilà que je n'ai pas de
maman avec yves montand à oui alors vous
disent qu'ils les truqueurs voleurs et
joueur escroc infidèle lachenaie de
déterrer des
ça c est quand à ça c'est pas ça
m'étonne de dire qu'on va le seul moment
où l'on rendait hommage à paris c'est
pour dire qu'il était sincère dans ses
engagements politiques mais qui s'est
trompé puisqu'il pensait que staline
était un mec formidable voilà alors face
et a résumé un peu approximatif on va
raconter d'histoires parce que les gens
ils la connaissent pas l'histoire
donc en fait ça a commencé quand mon
temps a fait une émission à la
télévision qui s'appelait d'yves la
crise et pour faire cette émission vient
de la cnil
il avait touché 800 mille balles voilà
et un jour de l'époque qui était énorme
voilà il avait touché 800 mille bas 80
millions d'anciens 80 millions d'anciens
francs et il demandait dans cette
émission aux gens de se serrer la
ceinture de faire un effort et un jour
dans mon zénith à moi denisot vous vous
dit mais vous n'êtes pas engagé par
rapport à yves montand tellement vous
faites rien etc et vous vous dites mais
moi si c'est pour gagner huit cent mille
balles pour dire aux gens de se serrer
la ceinture je veux bien le faire et à
ce moment là mon temps vous appelle non
il ya eu un quiproquo c'est qu'après il
y avait un jeune homme qui s'appelait
lamy qui est un imitateur entre l année
qui était un jeune belge et zuma veut
dire on va prendre un jeune pour pau
coupé l'émission de lettres dû trouver
sa sympathique
je ne savais pas ce qu'il faisait et il
a imité montant dans le pape et keira la
messe semble pâle donc j'ai trouvé que
c'était un peu too much jeudi à denisot
si tu crois pas que c'est un peu ça fait
appuyer un peu parce que c'était pas
dans le programme il dit non non tu
verras et le lendemain matin j'ai un
coup de téléphone de mon temps qui me
teddy qui veut me casser la gueule que
je suis tapé un [ __ ] que un sale [ __ ]
spd doit pas être tous les maux charmant
alors que et il se trouve que huit jours
avant j'avais déjeuné avec un ami pour
lui demander de l'argent pour abattue
elle qui était de chez elf à vieux
monsieur qui avait 82 ans et qui me dit
je me suis fait mon temps je dis comment
tu peux dire une chose pareille
celle qu'on dit de long parce que tout
le monde va accoucher de l'ensk est faux
ce que moi j'étais là quand j'ai dû
refaire la commencer ensemble on a vécu
comme des copains et non et c'est vrai
donc je vive
j'aime pas qu'on raconte ablakwa
alors me jim et non pas du tout et en
plus tu sais il était l'amant de rédac
est rédacteur qui était un immense
chanteur georges en lumière enfin qui
sortiront aussi impartial entre kwg
je me suis pas possible il me dit oui
alors jeté falla quelques amis apportant
un de musique houle qui me confirme que
tout le monde le sait il a été mais mais
pas ils étaient pas homosexuel
maintenant puisqu'il était homophobe
oui la balle était homophobe mais
surtout il était il aimait les femmes
mais pour réussir il avait passé par là
donc je vous ai mal venu c'est pas
pareil on ne sait pas s'ils allaient
collègues dont tu dois sauter bombe
sexuelle et papa voilà c'est pas c'est
pas assez parlé
il était embauché paris vise à réviser
ses tribunes et il y à un moment donné
ou à passer sur un c'est sur l'un de
l'autre s'appelle je ne porte pas de
jugement là dessus ça monkam en garde
pas sa mère
mais il était mal vu mais à ce moment là
vous dit à yves montand qui vous traite
de tout dix ans je lis simplement au
téléphone je lui ai dit écoute tu
écoutes une seconde la rédac heures un
silence absolu et voilà non mais pas de
verbe gens dont je vais vous dire c'est
pas très grave ce que j'ai à dire c'est
que ça vient au moment d'intégrer
lanseria au moment de benjamin castaldi
ils ne savaient pas j'en trouverais ça
je dois dire que si j'avais su que le
livre de guy nairay sortir avec le même
temps que le mien je n'aurais pas mis
ailleurs dans la première version que
j'ai de nos jolies créations sayette mba
ah bon j'avais enlevé alors qu'il avait
remis j'ai enlevé j'ai remis pour mon
entourage m'a dit ne le met pas parce
que les journalistes vont parler que de
ça elle a réagi marché professionnel je
ne raconte pas des trucs bizarres
commencer par un homme à 18 ans se faire
tripoter sépare en même temps 1
un homme qui couchent à la gare et 3 mai
qu'il ya un autre tennis halle [ __ ]
c'est juste sympa quoi manger de tout ce
qui vous a dit ce jour là
non j'ai été blessé pendant longtemps et
j'étais très malheureux que quelqu'un
que j'admirais comme lui quand robben
qu'intelligents entre vous et moi qu'ils
n'étaient pas tous les genres et puis
l'avait fait beaucoup de mal à simone
signoret et puis de dire enfin dans le
livre de caussade et quand il dit que
marilyn monroe n'était pas à coup un moi
qui vous parle
j'aurais bien aimé dormir ça va garder
tes photos maintenant marié l'état je me
mêle
en tout cas trop tu peux rester
tranquille là je te ferai rien à
dégueulasse à mener et puis un jour que
tu veux pas toucher à tous les cas ces
gens là vous ont laissé des souvenirs
parce que les gens vous voyez
aujourd'hui va vous racontiez le jour
dans suédoise par exemple j'avais
dessiné avec laetitia casta vous dites
on a parlé de la corse et de son fiancé
mais rien de plus
ça que c'est sûr vous avez pas de vivre
à écrire sur ce qui vous est arrivé avec
les anciens casta c'est vrai que elle
elle est jeune et qu'elle n'a pas une
vie mouvementée ce que je raconte à moi
dans mon livre ce sont les gens qui ont
eu des accidents ou des choses
extravagantes en moyenne chose qui me
fascine dans ce métier quand j'avais 17
ans je vais commencer dans ce métier par
la figuration je faisais des carpentier
un jour je m'habille en petit à petit
marin et ben ma première rencontre que
je vis et s était alors alors qu'il a
mis le doigt dans l'oeil football
une interview oui qui va vous permettre
d'enfin parler de vous qui peut parler
normalement il entend y compris oui jo
dan mozena besoin qui coince et charles
vanel ah non il est bien dans sa
peinture pardon non mais si oui c'est un
quart d'heure c'est extraordinaire on va
parler de lui mais à travers une
interview miroir mais bin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean-claude mais il ressemble à quoi
l'homme que vous voyez dans ce miroir
eux
il faudrait qu'ils perdent 15 kg il en a
vu beaucoup des vertes et des pas mûres
il a les cheveux blancs parce qu'il se
fait du souci temps en temps puis voilà
vous lui donnez quel âge comme ça moi je
n'aime pas donner d âge et qui est entre
60 et 70 ans
vous trouvez comment cet homme je ne
m'aime pas moi j'aime pas me regarder
il y avait beaucoup de films j'ai pas vu
de moi quand il ya une émission de des
gens que j'ai enregistrée qui passe à
tour je regarde pas donc ne nous mettez
pas un miroir en face de massy justement
qu'est-ce qui vous plaît pas dans cet
homme si je ne m'aimais pas je vivrai
pas avec moi je me serais suicidé depuis
longtemps le jeune homme accepte mais
enfin je me trouve parfois brillant
drôle méchant gourmands cet homme que
vous voyez vous voulez pas regarder la
leyre heureux y a que les imbéciles qui
sont heureux
comment on peut être heureux quand le
matin vous mettez votre radio moi jamais
tôt le matin on l'entend qu'à la guerre
en irak qui a la palestine qui a les
élections au bouge qui a le sida qui a
des enfants qui meurent de faim vous
vous être heureux il reste la drogue
l'alcool et les tranquillisants à
l'armée alors moi je me drogue pas et je
ne prends pas tranquillisants il a l'air
très polis comme ça vous pensez qu'il
peut dire des gros mots cet homme il dit
des gros mots et puis les révoltés
surtout les pas du tout une pépère à six
qui bouge pas d'après vous c'est quoi
son métier c'est beau comme on appelle
ça compteur baratineur il aime bien
parler
il aurait pu faire d'autres choses comme
métier avocat vous êtes un peu la même
chose mais ils gagnent plus d'argent
clientèle qui est fidèle
vous l'aimez bien cet homme oui vous le
regardez pas souvent un nom quand même
quand je maquille aux cards je fais très
vite
ouais c'est quoi la différence
principale entre l'homme que vous voyez
dans le miroir et vous y en a pas napa
je ne vois pas de différence vous n'êtes
que des cocteau les miroirs devrait
réfléchir deux fois avant de renvoyer
leur image
[Musique]
oubliez de dire
les gx aux éditions
j'accueille change de briey
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment savamment jean-claude très
élégant oui je me suis dit bon était en
pull-over il vaut mieux je sais quel
esprit cinnabun briani non cadrée de
vives autobiographique le ruisseau des
sages et j'ai oublié de vous dire qu'ils
se sont vendus comme à un million
d'exemplaires et ça fait des sous oui
enfin ça fait beaucoup pour les impôts
ouais la moitié à bombardier com mais je
mets la maison du temps souviens je les
mêmes essayer
oui c'est trop large pour toi j'en
connais d'autres c'est pas moi c'est pas
moi à ma place et ça écrit des pièces et
des pièces qui m'a aidé ps qui va après
soixante quinze dates à guichets fermés
du spectacle j'ai oublié de vous dire et
quatre mois aux bouffes parisiens vous
revenez avec un livre intitulé les
pensées les plus grands acteurs c'est
pas de moi c'est moi j'ai fait la
préface et j'ai choisi avec quelqu'un
les répliques les plus scintillantes
elles sont bien ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on croit toujours que les acteurs
sont un peu con way alors c'est bien
dans ce clip qu'on s'aperçoit que tout
de même l'acteur ne sont pas seulement
des perroquets vrai qu'ils ont de
l'esprit et d'humour j'ai vu tout à
l'heure avec deux là moi j'adore les
gens qui me font rire il ya là beaucoup
et il y en a une de vous dans le bouquin
n'ont jamais une de bruel ou de berléand
normand d'accord l'amérique des gens
très très connu mais non mais c'est
surtout des gens qui parlent du sexe de
l'amour
en avant propos vous dites citer les
pensées des autres c'est souvent
regretté de ne pas les avoir eus soi
même et c'est en prendre un peu la
responsabilité voilà bah oui c'est vrai
que je vous dis quelquefois quelle
chance sacha guitry avait de vivre avec
les gens il déjeunait avec capuche le
renard octave mirbeau feydeau
aujourd'hui on s'emballe un peu plus
alors on va voir si vous vous en
souvenez et on va voir si nos amis
savent qu'ils ont sans les auteurs on y
va mon coeur est français banques
internationales
holy dis bien très bien au procès c'est
une phrase de jean sont ces gens sans
que lui avait écrite pour le procès sas
est hermétique oui trop tard les hommes
et les femmes ont besoin d'une raison
pour faire l'amour les hommes ont juste
besoin d'un endroit vous y arrivez à
l'aide
marie c'est pas audi allen n'a c'est
billy crystal a béni cristal with the
dans mafia blues boom alors à la ba oui
bah oui alors que c'est internationale
saura vous en livre est international
fermer les maisons closes c'est plus
qu'un crime c'est un pléonasme aletti
bien dieu a créé l'alcool pour que les
femmes moches baisse quand même
via ce jour les chicots lui ce coluche
elle est bien ces jeunes la nuit d'amour
avec marilyn j'aurais préféré qu'on ne
le sut ce point si je puis dire alors su
ce point alors sans vie de mon temps en
temps oui c'était involontaire après je
ne suis pas un nouveau riche je suis un
ancien après il n'ya pas que l'argent
dans la vie y'a aussi des fourrures et
les bijoux mais west et marlene la belle
femme aussi elizabeth taylor
j'ai compris que le père noël n'existait
pas quand j'avais 5 ans chantera dans un
grand magasin il m'a demandé un
autographe petite actrice bravo c'est
pas évident
quand on s'est fait connaître en
choquant on ne peut plus choqué quand le
choc en plus luc ferry est l'une qui est
bien le soir des oscars j'étais entouré
de femmes qui n'arrêtait pas de me
demander je peux la toucher
malheureusement elle parlait de la
statuette
c'est ben affleck est bien le travail
d'équipé est essentielle en cas
d'erreurs ça permet d'accuser quelqu'un
d'autre génieau non un mec que tu adores
tu le cites schéma pourquoi oui high
link et bien vous avez beaucoup
d'ennemis oui comme tous les gens qui
n'aiment pas les cons pas mal dit riz
bernard blier
l'expérience est un peigne que vous
donne la vie quand vous êtes devenu
chauve lee briers encore vous savez ce
que c'est la connerie
imaginez une plage le soleil un whisky
avec des glaçons des nanas autour de
vous vous y êtes
et bien tout le reste c'est de la
connerie j'aime beaucoup la cuisine
chinoise mon plat préféré c'est le
numéro 27 ou diana jim carrey est bien
c'est que c'est vrai il ya trois choses
dans la vie que je supporte pas le café
brûlant le champagne tiède et les femmes
froide orson welles jamais été très
optimiste à tel point que j'ai toujours
hésité à m'abonner pour plus d'un an un
magazine c'est moi dutronc
une note de jim carrey qui est vachement
il est bon de jim carrey je savais pas
quand on parle à dieu c'est une prière
quand c'est lui qui nous parle sur la
schizophrénie
[Rires]
tiens justement le côté positif de la
mort c'est qu'on peut l'être en restant
couchés et une de pierre doris qu'on
salue ici à la rue qui est moins des
fans de kergrist les morts de la chance
ils ne voient leur famille qu'une fois
par an à la toussaint est mort un
millionnaire c'est un milliardaire qui
vient de payer ses impôts
[Rires]
robert lamoureux et la dernière le point
commun entre tous les hommes que j'ai
aimé c'est moi jeanne moreau jeanne
moreau bravo
vous êtes là vous pourriez nous dire
quelques mots
darry cowl vous qui parlez tellement
bien les morts au moins il est vivant
encore ma j'ai la chance de mon premier
film j'ai fait avec lui c'était l'ami de
la famille et les côtés on verra le
triporteur
le treport patrie potter ou triporteur
c'était après mais c'était un il était
plein de c'est un lutin c'était un
enfant il jouait beaucoup card au casino
ils adorent et les femmes il était
amoureux de béatrice altarriba mais
amoureux comme un étudiant comme un
enfant et une portée des fleurs eut
acheté petits cadeaux des bagues il
était délicieux parce que il tremblait
pour eux lui qui voulait lui plaire
alors il a pesé rire beaucoup c'est ce
qu'il est et ce après sa foi s'est passé
duction je crois que jusqu'au bout de sa
vie il a fait croire à sa femme qu'il
était internet
quelle est la plus belle preuve d'amour
que nous arrivera à tous on en parlait
tout à l'heure avec luc ferry le jour où
ça vous arrivera qui souhaitez-vous pour
faire votre éloge funèbre et bien je
vais vous dire un jour j'étais à
l'enterrement comme par hasard une gt
gaudette de long il me prend la main et
me dit il me regarde ça brive violent il
dit c'est moi qui parlerai quand tu
seras bord alors je lis mais pour moi ça
serais toi et moi je parlais pas de toit
s'était morts bilan parce que c'est
comme ça ne prendre que ces deux longues
ses talents qui s'y collera c'est ce
qu'on va faire maintenant une interview
au camp
[Musique]
jean-claude vous trouvez pas que les
jeunes acteurs ne respecte plus assez
leurs aînés ont respecté c'est pas très
amusant je préférais qu'il les aime
vous trouvez pas que je suis pas de
votre temps les actrices s'habiller pas
tout comme des filles de petite vertu
aujourd'hui connu quand j'étais jeune
oui mais c'est bien petite vertu
dre pas qu'avant n'ai pas besoin
d'effets spéciaux pour un film
spectaculaire
oui c'est vrai que quand on voit les
enfants du paradis les effets spéciaux
c'était prévert way serait pas que les
spectateurs maintenant au cinéma ils ont
pu de manière et bouffe du pop corn et
si le beauf à l'entente avec ça va ouais
c'est vrai que c'est dommage de voir
disparaître toutes ses salles de cinéma
ah oui ça c'est triste
les multiplexes moi j'aime beaucoup les
petites salles ray c'est un souvenir
d'enfance trouvait pas qu'un cas film en
dvd ça remplacera jamais un film dans
une salle quand même à bâle à aller au
cinéma c'est une cérémonie avec une fête
vous serez pas qu'avant les journalistes
il respectait les acteurs il se prenait
pas pour des stars
non parce que j'ai connu un journaliste
important qui a dit du mal des enfants
du paradis donc tout le monde peut se
tromper
ouais mais lui on sait plus qui il est
ouais j'sais pas que la télévision a tué
le cinéma finalement et qu'on sait pas
comment ça se terminera pour elle non
parce que l'intelligent on fait des
films de télévision il ya une différence
entre les films de télévision et les
films de cinéma soit pas que les
scénarios actuellement beaucoup moins
d'intérêt quand même
non parce qu'il ya des gens qui écument
le très très beau scénario vous savez
j'ai pas encore vu le film de chabrol
mais je vais y aller demain mais j'ai vu
le fauteuil d'orchestre est un beau film
de tom daley comme ça construit bien
écrit alors je trouve dit triste un peu
aujourd'hui que les rôles secondaires
disparaissent ouais quand je suis arrivé
à 2,6 maya donc 50 ans pour moi pauline
carton jean tissier carette daliot jules
berry étaient des vedettes
aujourd'hui il ya des vedettes il ya
moins d'acteurs les revendeurs comme ça
voilà plein ah oui non mais c'est pas
les allées déroule soin d'elle c'est une
troupe
mais art et il m'avait dit dans leur
hôtel du nord elle m'avait dit le jouer
et moi la tournée huit jours
dans hôtel du nord annabella jean pierre
aumont cette semaine on se souvienne qui
sait trés pas que le cinéma est mort
avec françois truffaut
non il a il a été malade parce que quand
françois est parti il a manqué quelques
uns au cinéma mais il yad'autres
françois truffaut qui arrive crois pas
qu'une star en jeans et une faute de
goût quand même pas une star qu'est ce
que c'est qu'une star moi j'aime
beaucoup les gens de j'ai connu barlin
de vitry je le tague arbaud elle faisait
rêver parce qu'elles savaient des
déshabillés qui faisait plus penser à
beaucoup de choses qui étaient plus
érotique que de déchirer blue jeans soit
pas que la promo c'est pénible en plus
vous parler de sa vie privée et où côte
est avec vous mon cher c'est un pote or
il ya des moments où je me demande si je
vais pas changer et que je vais pas
devenir normal quand je vois le jeune
fille pareil
enfin bon on n'est pas lourd allons-y je
tiens vous avez quatre cartes
il faut dire qu'une seule la carte
senior ça tombe bien vous avez droit à
une couverture pour vos jambes si vous
le désirez chauffante
elle est allée au coin tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
souvent classé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
et
alors oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]